[Applause]
[Music]
so far the Ukrainian War looks like the
modern version of the David vs Goliath
Legend almost a year after Russian tanks
were at the gates of Kiev it's now the
Russians who seem to be on the ropes but
what if Moscow was trying at any cost to
reverse the situation could the tables
be turned again well cast your eyes on
this news night Russia completes partial
mobilization of citizens for Ukraine war
this news story is from November 2022.
at the time of making this video January
2023 it is not yet known exactly how
many new soldiers Russia has mobilized
but the target was 300 000. if this were
the case we'd be talking about almost
double the number of soldiers who began
the invasion in February last year but
not only that some say the numbers could
be even higher Russia preparing to
mobilize extra 500 000 conscripts claims
Ukraine to what extent this is true we
do not know but everything indicates
that something is brewing and if
Ukrainian intelligence is not mistaken
Russia could already have more than 280
thousand troops on the battlefield and
may now want to add another 500 000 more
[Music]
in other words we could be talking about
more than 700 000 soldiers in combat or
ready to go into battle this might
explain for example why the start of
2023 has been frenetic with huge
shipments of heavy weapons and advanced
missiles being announced virtually every
day to Ukraine by the US the UK and
other Allied countries Denmark for
example has delivered to Ukraine the
bulk of its artillery check this out
Denmark to donate 19 frenchmaids Caesar
howitzers to Ukraine Ukraine has to be
prepared 500 000 additional soldiers
recruited as a lot of soldiers but as
for Russia I know what many of you are
thinking how could they train them in
such a short time if in 2022 when their
arsenals were full of materials the
Russians had logistical problems how are
they going to arm and feed so many extra
people and yes you are right sending so
many troops is no easy task and as we
will see later in this video Putin's
partial mobilization has been anything
but a cakewalk now we are still talking
about hundreds of thousands of new
soldiers they may be better or worse
armored With Better or Worse training or
more or less equipment but at least
these figures should be considered with
respect if this mobilization does
ultimately happen it is high enough
number for us to dedicate a video to the
matter here on visualpolitik so the
question we are asking today is have
they really been able to recruit that
many people in Russia how did they do it
what consequences could this have for
the Kremlin to what extent should they
be worried and Kiev today we're going to
answer all these questions but first
let's look at some history
Beggars can't be choosers
on the 20th of September the Duma which
is the Russian national parliament
passed the mobilization law Russia needs
300 000 new recruits and the question
many of you may be asking is what
exactly does this mean I mean from that
point on can any citizen be sent to war
how has this mobilization been carried
out well the first thing we have to keep
in mind is that not all Russians can be
called up the first requirement is to
have previous military experience for
example if you fought in the 2008 war in
Georgia you could be called back you
would have to pass a medical examination
and you might be forced to go to Ukraine
thinking of skipping Town well be
prepared because you could end up with a
present sentence ranging from 3 to 10
years so far as expected it is still a
war after all what's more the salary
promised by Putin is not bad at all
Putin has said that each mobilized
person will receive 195 000 rubles the
equivalent about three thousand dollars
a month of course this is in theory in
practice it may be a very different
story 100 drafted Russian soldiers went
on strike refusing to fight in Ukraine
after not getting paid report says as
you can imagine the first problem with
such immobilization is the political
cost it goes with seeing very few are
happy to go to a war
so as soon as the Kremlin made the
announcement of the first mobilization
the first protests were organized in the
country's major cities in fact since
then Putin has considerably reduced his
public appearances for example at the
end of every year the Russian president
used to hold a press conference with
questions from the public in 2022 that
tradition came to an end the conference
was canceled but the question now is
firstly how can you recruit three
hundred thousand people and if it does
eventually happen half a million more
and a country as big as Russia will each
Russian region has recruitment centers
for which quotas are set these are the
same recruiting centers through which
the 260 000 young people who do pass
their military service every year go
through and this is where the second big
problem comes in as you can imagine many
Russians do not want to die in Ukraine
by now you have all heard about the mass
Exodus of young Russians who have fled
the country to avoid going to war we are
talking about upwards of 700 000 people
and what do you think happened to those
who did not manage to escape well in
many cases things like this since the
Russian invasion of Ukraine there have
been more than a dozen reported attempts
to set fire to military recruitment
offices in Russian regions that's right
we are not just talking about protests
we are talking about people who have
gone so far as to throw Molotov
cocktails at recruiting offices we've
seen videos of protests complained from
recruits in short this massive
mobilization has not exactly gone
smoothly however by the 28th of October
2022 the Minister of Defense announced
that the first mobilization had been
successfully completed and the question
you were all probably wondering is were
they really able to mobilize 300 000
troops or is this just another of
Russia's many Bluffs in this war
think of it this way every year the
Russian army conducts two recruitment
campaigns one in the spring and one in
the Autumn these two campaigns last
about three months each around 130 000
young people are mobilized in these
campaigns however now we are talking
about mobilizing more than twice as many
people in less than half the time and in
the middle of protests and Molotov
cocktail attacks is it really possible
to do something like that well what many
experts are already seeing is that
Russia can indeed mobilize 300 000
reservists but with a lot of quotation
marks on the one hand criminals who have
been in prison have also been included
there have also been mistakes such as
sending soldiers who are over the age
limit but these are all things that even
the Kremlin has acknowledged however
there are suspicions that the Crux of
the matter is not exactly this
you see in theory this mobilization was
intended to re-enlist reservists with
combat experience or who at least had
been professional soldiers not simple
conscripts keep in mind that in Russia
almost all men between 18 and 27 years
old have to do compulsory military
service that lasts 12 months in other
words right now there are 127 500
conscripts we're about to finish their
12 months of service and return to their
civilian jobs are they ready to enter
combat well no but the recruiting
centers need to meet the quotas that
have been imposed on them and if you're
a long time follower of visualpolitik
you already know that the Russian
Administration is characterized by one
thing lies and then more lies the
directors of the centers want to keep
their superiors Happy who in turn want
to keep the high general staff happy and
so on and so forth conclusion we bring
these recruits who are about to go home
we put them on a professional soldier's
contract and we send them to Ukraine how
many recruits are we talking about is it
being done on a frequent basis we can't
know but the rumors exist and this is
certainly not a far-fetched Theory now
with more or less experience we are
talking about tens and tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands even of people who
will gradually arrive on the battlefield
and the question is to what extent could
they tip the balance towards Russia well
we're gonna find that out now
a meat grinder
[Music]
according to the Russian government by
the end of October and the beginning of
November 2022 the first mobilization had
already met its goal since then tens and
tens of thousands of these new soldiers
have been transferred to Ukraine and the
question now is what has Russia
mobilized so many people for it may seem
obvious the first objective has to be to
reinforce the weakened Russian Lanes
which had allowed the front to stagnate
to a certain extent and in some cases
the Russians have returned to try and
carry out some small offensives in
addition Russia is believed to be
planning a second major attack on
Ukraine some speak of an offensive that
would begin in late winter others
believe that they will wait until spring
some say it will be limited to the Don
Bass But Ukrainian intelligence speaks
of a new attack on Kiev which would come
from Belarus the Russians are preparing
fresh troops I have no doubt that they
will go for Kiev again I'll extenderski
Ukrainian Colonel general of course it
is one thing to recruit people and quite
another to prepare organize and equip
them and I think we all know that Russia
is having a lot of problems with that
it's something we have talked about here
on visualpolitik in past videos in
addition the Russian managers are not
only thinking about recruitment it has
also been noted that Russia is preparing
t-62 tanks from the 1960s in order to
send them to Ukraine and that in itself
is a serious problem
however many soldiers they managed to
mobilize it is most likely that the bulk
of the heavy weapons they sent to
Ukraine if they attempt another strike
will be junk with a few more modern
pieces here and there for the more
complex missions because the truth is
that in spite of all the casualties and
losses suffered Russia still has a lot
of Soviet rubbish to let loose whatever
the case from The Institute of the study
of War they have reported that Russian
troops are moving more heavy equipment
the move is from the rear of luhansk to
areas near the current front Lane
between kharkiv and luhansk and indeed
it is in this region that the Russians
are likely to focus as well as the
Donetsk or blast where they could
attempt to capture the entire region
along these lines for example some
limited operations are already underway
to Halt Ukrainian advances and recapture
positions lost on the criminal front and
Ukraine's own foreign minister dimitro
culeba is saying something very similar
every one expect a major Russian
offensive in the first months of 2023
[Music]
however due to the lack of training of
many of those mobilized not much is
expected of them either I know what some
of you will be thinking visualpolitik is
already at it again with their
anti-russian propaganda but not at all
in fact some of those mobilize could be
of great use to the Russian army for
example those with previous experience
and professions such as mechanics or
medicine could be of great help but
generally speaking in any war and even
more so in modern Wars training and
experience is a very important element
not all soldiers have the same combat
level and yes it is true that proportion
of those mobilized were sent to the
front while the rest remained training
in Russia however so far we can't say
that the first Contact has gone too well
and those who are still in training are
not likely to have much time either this
is the one major handicap that explains
why in most cases the mobilization has
become a real hell for the Russians who
have suffered it when it comes down to
it most of them are nothing more than
bodies that end up being thrown by Putin
onto the Battleground to bulk up the
front lines in an effort to delay the
ukrainians perhaps waiting for the end
of winter to play in his favor evidently
the expectations of these people are
pretty dire and in fact many of them
know this perfectly well two weeks of
training doesn't prepare you for this
Russian mobilized man tells the guardian
take the case of Alexi agavanov who is
mobilized along with 570 other men from
the veronics region in an interview he
gave to the Guardian newspaper he
recounted his disastrous experience at
the front among other things he stated
that of the 570 recruited after a few
weeks only 130 were still alive many of
those who survived lost their minds
after what happened nobody wants to go
back we were completely exposed
statements of a Russian mobilized person
to the guardian but wait a moment
because this is not even the biggest
problem while it is true that everything
indicates that these mobilized people
are not well trained the next question
we should be asking ourselves is how are
they going to be armed so let's take a
look at that no
foreign
s come from
there is one question I am going to
throw out there do the calculations 700
000 Russians have left the country
another 300 000 are leaving for Ukraine
in total we are talking about 1 million
workers who have left the country we are
quietly talking about more than 1.4
percent of the country's working
population and a little more than two
percent if there is ultimately a second
conscription and those are big numbers
especially when we consider that among
the Russians who have fled are many
highly qualified young people if we add
to this loss the fact that Russian
Society is seriously aging the question
is how will the Russian economy be able
to produce wealth who is going to
manufacture the weapons they need so
badly yes it is true one of the groups
excluded from the mobilizations are
those who work in Armament companies but
this is not enough and check it out
because this is something recognized by
the Russian authorities themselves the
Personnel shortage at Russian defense
Enterprises is about 400 000 people
although this is not anything new in
other videos we have already told you
about Russia's weapons issues in 2017
NPO novator a Russian Arms Company was
only capable of producing 60 missiles in
six months and naturally as you can
imagine the intensity of the war in
Ukraine requires much more than that to
give you an idea on several occasions
Russia has launched more than twice that
number of missiles in a single day
and not only that it is estimated that
in November 2022 alone Russia fired
nearly 20 000 artillery rounds in
addition in one month they have launched
no fewer than 1 200 caliber missiles
according to the Royal United Services
Institute rusi Russia fired more
ammunition in two days than the UK has
in its regular stockpile in addition
Russian forces have already used almost
all of their iskinder sort range
missiles
[Music]
in other words the Russian army
simultaneously has two major problems
they go through artillery at a very
rapid rate and they have problems
producing more at the necessary rate of
replacement and the fact is that
contrary to what Putin perhaps thought
China has not sold him weapons on a
massive scale as has been speculated at
the beginning of the war and if this in
itself is already concerning for Russia
there is another factor that makes
things even worse for them International
sanctions
think of it this way conventional
bullets that we use for a rifle are one
thing Precision missiles are quite
another to manufacture normal bullets
Russia has the materials and the only
thing that it may fall a little is the
industry and the pace of production but
what about Precision missiles no way
it's a totally different story a large
number of Russian missiles are equipped
with microchips traditionally supplied
by the West this means that due to
sanctions Russia is running out of
precision missiles because there is a
shortage of these chips Russian weapons
in Ukraine powered by hundreds of
western parts report says of course most
of these western parts are manufactured
in only a few countries we are mainly
talking about Taiwan South Korea the
United States the Netherlands Germany
the United Kingdom and Japan that's why
on the Russian side we have started to
see all kinds of Weaponry botches that
look like something out of a spoof movie
we have reports from the ukrainians that
when they find Russian military
equipment it is full of semiconductors
that they took out of dishwashers and
refrigerators Gina Raymondo U.S
Secretary of Commerce who knows maybe
that explains the images we have seen of
Ukrainian houses completely stripped
without refrigerators and washing
machines after the passage of Russian
troops through that area I mean who
knows but of course taking all this into
account the question is what is Putin
doing to change this
[Music]
well given the sanctions Putin has
actually very little room for maneuver
for now the Russian dictator is taking
advantage of his good relationship with
Iran one example would be the constant
Iranian drone attacks that have become a
daily occurrence in the war in Ukraine
and take note because these drones are
followed by short-range ballistic
missiles of the fatah 110 and zolfagar
types that is why in response to Iran's
arm sales some countries such as the
United Kingdom have already introduced
new sanctions packages not only against
senior Russian military leaders but also
against Iranian businessmen and
officials the U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken had this to say the
United States will continue to use every
tool at its disposal to disrupt such
transfers and impose consequences on
those involved in such activities
Anthony blinken U.S Secretary of State
on the other hand there have been
accusations from the United States of
arms purchases by Russia from North
Korea accusations that of course have
been dismissed by Russia as pure hearsay
and speculation the fact is that with or
without the North Koreans the Russians
have already begun to use degraded
ammunition in some cases we could be
talking about rockets and bullets
manufactured 40 years ago and what
happens when you use old stuff well you
can probably guess there are projectiles
that get stuck in Russian shells and
others that are launched but don't
explode when they reach their target but
let's not kill ourselves well all this
may be a good thing an advantage for
Kiev in the development of the war the
truth is that it is not good use for
Ukraine in the long run
on the one hand it is true that it is
difficult to win a war with outdated
ammunition but this also means that
shells that have not yet exploded may do
so later in undesirable circumstances
but not only that since Russia has so
far been unable to win the war it is now
starting to single out and attack easier
targets even if it means perpetrating
crimes against humanity I am of course
talking about civilian targets something
Russia is now starting to pursue in
order to discourage Ukrainian resistance
Russian missile strike on apartment
building in nepro kills 40 people
Ukraine officials say think of it this
way what is the use of destroying a
residential building from the point of
view of warfare none why would Russian
fighter jets plan such an attack the
reason is simple they can do nothing
else and with such vicious attacks they
hope to discourage resistance and force
Ukraine to accept a ceasefire agreeable
to Moscow it is exactly the same
strategy they have shown with power
plants and water treatment plants
specifically the Dimitri Brew attack was
carried out by kh-22 missiles these
missiles are from the Soviet era they
are characterized by two things they are
very inaccurate but at the same time
they are almost impossible for Ukraine
to intercept at least with the Arsenal
they currently have so what the outcome
Russia has used them on several
occasions to attack heavily populated
areas once again they do not destroy
Pacific military targets but it is
enough for them to fall on a city to
kill dozens of civilians
the thing is at this point many of you
may be thinking but then is Russia
doomed to lose this war are all those
hundreds of thousands of new soldiers
marching straight into a meat grinder
well in a way yes however we also have
to look at the other side of the coin
[Music]
Ukraine is totally dependent on Western
Aid to arm its Army and although up to
now the supply of armaments to Ukraine
has been constant and everything
indicates that this will continue to be
so the truth is that if in the end this
is something that does not depend on the
ukrainians but on International
solidarity and this could become a
problem or at the very least a major
weakness secondly even if the West
continues to supply ammunition the
arsenals of Europe and the United States
also have their limits and the situation
right now is far from ideal at least as
far as equipment is concerned and
although it seems that we are not yet at
Breaking Point the truth is that news
stories like this one need to be taken
seriously Europe is rushing arms to
Ukraine but running out of ammo Wall
Street Journal at least as far as
Western Europe is concerned which has
the worst equipped armies perhaps The
Only Exception is the United Kingdom the
United States for its part is drawing on
its giant stockpiles it had in Israel
and South Korea for war situations this
alone could cover conventional
ammunition needs be that as it may we
are not yet at a critical point the
latest arms deliveries are proof of
there are still plenty of warehouses
full not to mention the entire Western
military industrial complex but at this
point the question is over to you is
Ukraine prepared for what seems to be
coming and do you think the Russian
recruits will change the Dynamics of the
war you can leverage your answers in the
comments below and as always don't
forget that here on visualpolitik we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to this Channel and hit the
little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know all
the best and I'll see you next time
[Music]